jojo was geht leute hier ist euer magst
und herzlich willkommen zum heutigen
video hier bestimmt ist habe ich gestern
ein video hochgeladen wo ich pokémon go
gespielt habe und ja ich habe das video
hochgeladen und habe ganz normal nachdem
es online war so die bewertungen und die
kommentare gecheckt zuerst hab ich
gesehen und es hat ein paar mehr discs
verstehe ich weil es halt auch so ein
hack video waren dass nicht jeder super
cool findet aber dann habe ich in die
kommentare geschaut und wäre es mir
einen kommentar unter die augen gekommen
und ok und zwar schreibt jemand jetzt
wissen wir wo du wohnst ab heute wirst
du von fans belagert ich denke hey was
reden die denn und ich gucke mir
nächsten kommentar an und jetzt weiß
jeder wo er wohnt und ich saß da dachte
ich mir das video nochmal angeschaut und
habe gesehen ok tatsächlich man sieht
die karte weil logischerweise wir
spielen ja pokémon go und dann habe ich
ein bisschen weiter gelesen in
kommentaren abgeguckt okay wie viele
leute haben das jetzt schon erkannt oder
so und ich gucke weiter und wir jedem
jetzt seinen wohnort verraten hat und
ich habe mich von meinem kopf gefasst
die es schon klar dass die leute jetzt
herausfinden können wo du wohnst nimmt
das video am besten wieder runter
du hast gerade so gut wie deine adresse
veröffentlicht und ich setze da denkt
mir so ok aber in dem moment leute in
dem moment kriege ich eine e mail an
mein business e mail account von youtube
welcher übrigens nicht für private
nachrichten ist sondern halt für
business kontakte wurde war ich schaue
in meine e-mails rein und sehe dass hier
wenn du das pokémon go heck video nicht
löscht veröffentliche ich deine adresse
ich sag nur punkt punkt punkt da habe
ich mir erst mal gedacht okay jetzt will
er mich erpressen und hat mir natürlich
geantwortet und abgeschrieben
ich sag nur anzeige diese e mail von
iris erpresserisch und könnte schon
alleine um den zusätzlichen
straftatbestand den das veröffentlich
meine adresse darstellen würden durch
mich zur anzeige gebracht werden
also besser für dich du bleibst ruhig er
antwortet sorry war klar
aber jetzt mal die top macht lieber ein
zensierten rhi upload davon ist nur ein
tipp
du solltest am besten einfach nur die
puppe stop zensieren zu dem zeitpunkt
habe ich bereits gehört wie die ersten
fan treffen vor meiner tür stattgefunden
haben weil bekanntlicherweise habe ich
ja meine adresse offengelegt und leute
natürlich ich habe ihm geantwortet hat
beschrieben
selbstverständlich habe ich mein video
nicht bei mir zuhause angefangen denkt
doch mal nach
ein hack mit dem man sich bewegen kann
ohne zu laufen und ich fange mein video
bei mir zu hause an
traurig dass uns so viele andere mich
also dumm einschätzen leute wirklich es
ging nicht mehr klar auf twitter haben
die leute geschrieben
das video lässt das video man weiß wo du
wohnst auf youtube hunderte kommentare
natürlich war das nicht mein wohnort was
da wirklich es war so schlimm es ist
natürlich nicht mein wohl gut gewesen
okay du mir auch übrigens leid dass ich
das mit ein bisschen schauspielen
angefangen habe aber ich dachte nur das
wäre ganz lustig dass die leute die sich
so gefreut haben ja wir wissen wo er
wohnt jetzt haben wir ihn fallen der
hand und kann ihn erpressen alter was
was ist das eigentlich natürlich nicht
gestreckt mal euren kopf an
logischerweise bin ich bevor ich das
video aufgenommen habe erstmal mit dem
heck eine ganze weile weg gelaufen dass
man halt nicht die pokerstop von meiner
haustür sieht bringen ich dachte einfach
nur darüber muss man sprechen man muss
darüber sprechen die die leute darauf
reagieren und generell also wirklich
insbesondere diese app dieser
erpressungsversuch ich könnte mit dieser
e-mail insofern ist nicht raus kriege
wer das ist einfach eine strafanzeige
gegen unbekannt stellen weil das eine
versuchte erpressung ist wem ich quasi
zwingen
dieses video zu löschen ohne halt
wirklich zu wissen wo ich tatsächlich
wurden aber das tut ja nichts zur sache
ist ja trotzdem
der versuch einer erpressung ich habe
mir natürlich auch gedacht als ich es
hochgeladen habe okay die sex-videos ein
bisschen kontrovers aber ich fand's cool
und wollte enteilen und dann kommen
leute die mich erpressen wollen
really also wirklich so was ich habe mir
echt gedacht okay
okay soweit sind wir gekommen weil ich
ein video mache was anderen leuten nicht
gefällt
wohlgemerkt ohne irgendwelche tutorials
zu geben oder sondern nur das ding zu
zeigen da war ich wirklich ein bisschen
enttäuscht muss ich sagen aber ich gehe
einfach mal davon aus dass jemand der so
etwas macht einfach kein treuer
zuschauer ist sage ich mal und einfach
nur ein punkt punkt punkt ist also
abschließend noch mal nein leute das war
gestern nicht meine adresse auch beim
pokémon bobby davor war es das nicht ich
bin nicht so dumm und nehm direkt vor
meiner haustür pokémon grau auf weil
auch ich weiß tatsächlich dass man bei
pokemon go sehenswürdigkeiten bei den
poker stopps hat und die
sehenswürdigkeiten kann man
logischerweise googeln und natürlich
jeder denkt okay du bist du dumm aber
vor allen dingen wenn ich ein hack video
mache wirklich ein hack mit dem man
weggehen kann wieso sollte ich dann
nicht weggehen sondern direkt vor meiner
haustür aufnehmen naja ich hab das
gestern entdeckt diese ganzen kommentare
und so als mit meinem besten freund
unterwegs war und wir dachten okay wie
lustig wäre es eigentlich wenn wir mal
zu der adresse bei der ich das video
gestartet habe oder in die gegend
hingehen und schauen ob wirklich jemand
so doof ist da hinzugehen weil falls ihr
tun mir die leute die eigentlich dort
wohnen wo ich das video angefangen habe
wirklich leid weil dann stehen plötzlich
irgendwelche böswilligen kinder wie das
super toll finden dass irgendjemand
einen fehler gemacht hat vor der haustür
und warten darauf dass ich raus oder
reingeht
alles in allem kann man abschließend
sagen solltet ihr irgendwann die chance
haben
herauszufinden wo ein youtuber wohnt
dann beides für euch seid froh darüber
ihr wisst wo er wohnt cool aber
respektiert die privatsphäre schreibt in
die kommentare ohne können wissen wo er
wohnt weil logischerweise jeder kann
dann im fall von mir den angeblichen
wohnort mit einem google mit einer
google suchanfrage sofort herausfinden
aber wenn ihr wirklich wisst wo jemand
wohnt behalt ist für euch seid fair weil
auch youtuber wollen ihre privatsphäre
und das ist eine sache die ihr uns als
zuschauer schenken könnte wir
respektieren können
soja dann hoffe ich ihr fand jetzt
genauso lustig wie ich dass die leute
alle so extrem abgegangen sind und sich
einfach komplett teilweise gefeiert
haben dafür dass wir wüssten wo ich
wohne ja okay ich musste einfach darüber
ein video machen ich fand das viel zu
lässig okay machs gut bis zum nächsten
mal